[Música]
eu e alguns amigos encontrarmos numa
zona piscatória com algumas palavras
cheias os anos a falar for com elas
uma delas registrou a falar for comigo
porque aqui nós também sabemos falar
português
uma outra acrescento eu já estudei até
8ª classe norge estamos isso registamos
a indignação delas outra vez numa ação
de campanha
acha que seria muito mais eficaz na
comunicação com ser reunião é for é que
eu passei o cheiro ser o chefe da
comunidade vai estar sob minha senhora
nossa que todos entendemos português por
carsale português isso com sua fazer
qualquer coisa na minha cabeça
o cânon a tua vontade pensávamos que são
tomé é for seria muito bem a fome seria
melhor a punidas refletem sobre isso eu
portei na a uma situação que ocorreu
olha o conselho minha carreira no ensino
em um player mesmo sexo no fim do
primeiro período eu tenho um aluno nunca
tinha aberto a boca eu não conseguia
porque eu não falava mais que eu
tentasse um dia muito assim é o boteco
da fama da boneca famosíssima capital
sabes cantar eu posso pé começa a cantar
em forro essa nossa perto papo rodar
suba átila lins ato vedado
a gala de natal começar por si só e toda
turma bater palmas e lançada e era perto
era na escola de almeirim eu cheguei à
conclusão de que se calhar era o
primeiro nirá aulas da quinina pelo novo
player não falava ficava sempre
reservado não falava com ninguém e desde
então eu tenho feito uma espécie de
cruzada é chamar a atenção para a
situação em linguística das crianças que
nós tivemos na nossa sala de aula
nós temos uma ilusão linguística com nos
leva a pensar que todos são tomé se fala
nisso mas o português que aquelas
senhoras paula i e xi e o senhor já da
união de campanha as pessoas lá falou
este português que nós dizemos assim ó e
molhou uma chuva e capinha o que estava
muito frio está preparado
isto põe problemas novata problemas de
intercompreensão terrível aos regimes
quando estamos a falar com pessoas falam
acho que toda vez que não são assunto
mesmo porque por curso do mês tem o
poder do olhar a chuva é vencer tapado
pelo pa
o som começa a etapa e por aí fora
eu topei pa
e então é acho que essas questões têm a
ver com a situação linguística no país
nós temos um língua portuguesa que
conviva bonita com 4 criou sem um deus o
forro e então essas línguas vivem de
interferências mútuas
eu vou mostrar não apenas sobre o caso
do for é o som começa traduz no
português com for eu devo lembrar e 88%
nas palavras do for são de origem
portuguesa todos criou são base
portuguesa
o forno é aquele que talvez comporta
maior percentagem de palavras mas a
estrutura fundo rogge e sintática das
línguas veria o que aconteceu com nossos
são diversos
ganhamos um português traduzimos qual
for
depois o enviamos novamente português
nós temos muitas versões em que se
verifica essa tala incompreensão
aliás a bela falou do o enunciado que
ouviu que coordene coisa pequena
de acordo com coisa
quer dizer que colocou aí então nós
pegarmos nas palavras e voltarmos a
enviar por favor é para o nosso
portuguesa vale autoral de são tomé e
príncipe e assim nós temos você em algum
no sapato
você e eu no meu paulo é você e eu não
vi o pão sem algum sapato e outras
coisas eu me acha estar a chorar
bebeto vai chorar muito e eu morrerei
ele mas é nosso calo
isto tem a ver com essa chama estágio
interferências mútuas e tem a ver também
com uma coisa que sim eu julgo tratasse
de é aquilo que a indústria chama uma
situação de negocia
enfim nós temos duas línguas mas não
dominar sua estrutura nenhuma delas nós
não estamos bem as fronteiras onde
estamos a falar português e quando
passamos por os nossos criou sozinha
também por furto
então uma safra a outra nos bairros a
avançar e nós vamos continuar com este
problema que eu até hoje tem o confronto
com esse problema
na minha turma é os alunos e já na
universidade escrevem e às vezes não se
observa que a china é nós partimos dessa
ilusão na indústria ou de falarmos do
bicho desses e ainda por cima
halo que encoraja essa ilusão
linguística que é é é a relação entre a
língua portuguesa de pilotos que faz com
que a língua portuguesa seja é língua de
prestígio mas com que ela tomou soro
a queira falar e que se afirma que quer
afirmar-se através dela é
falar eu for com meu cabelo disse no
início para certas pessoas para elas é
como que se considerar e durante burras
povos
ainda por cima o ao estatuto dos testes
de língua portuguesa viu-se forçado a
independência paradoxalmente é que os
nossos dirigentes só falam português é
quase nunca se comunicam em criou com o
povo
eu estou vindo a suportar com uma rica
literatura portuguesa e língua de
comunicação social a todos aqueles que
sonham
é o que pretendem que inspirou uma
promoção sócio cultural tem que estar
preparado disse ainda que seja esse
trecho é que é o nosso variados falar
çom começou a variar português de são
tomé e príncipe e então devemos todos
falar for de vinhos todos falar fu por
razões de vária ordem
uma delas e no meu em 3 porque eu sou
professora de português é que quando se
domina bem a estrutura de uma língua
pode ser bonita das outras meninas
é durante a minha carreira eu verifiquei
que as crianças e jovens do psd
angulares falar mãe escreviam
incomparavelmente melhor desde que as
crianças forças porque porque eles
levaram já a consumir dade as estruturas
do flu angular ou do príncipe em si
tanto eu acho que seria do em 3 para a
própria língua portuguesa que nós
falássemos mas for mas quem fala foram
os mais velhos e depois eu e reduzida
o folclore na música tradicional nas
pessoas tradicionais do foco próprio
collor
o forum e ajudado ainda hoje aos jovens
e crianças quase uma criança forram bala
for em chamas
olha só o forro e circular forno é como
se fosse uma coisa do outro conhecer
perfeitamente normal é que nós é nós
olhamos não só para as nossas línguas
nacionais mas também para outros
elementos da nossa cultura consec foi a
origem é como se nós fôssemos os
estrangeiros olhar com as nossas
próprias coisas é se uma mulher aparece
trajada com nó sul vai trabalhar há
cinco anos o gênio que não foram de 8
março em envelopes tempo ou numa festa
da freguesia perguntam logo porque tá
vestir essa e deve existir muitas outras
coisas e então nós falarmos for
circunstancial minas quando estávamos em
situações diferentes da minha
sentimentos muito fãs
o quando é não queremos que os outros
entendam que estamos acostumados a dizer
principalmente quando estamos lá fora
muitos nós nos aprimorarmos e for quando
estamos lá fora
inclusivamente eu não deixava falar em
casa e é propósito às vezes é mal dão se
mal ao caso numa as meninas estavam no
metro em portugal e estava um velho
olhar muito para elas e elas faziam for
eu te olhar sentar porque o olhar justas
caiu o teto nos por mim e outra de gil
não em outros jogos cuidado é o mais
velho da boba
o mercado ainda é boba e os cinco homens
em um seio do metro e assim nenê e
chegando aí
e elas ficaram a metro estatuto das
celas ficarão os lados
nós passamos por muitas coisas dessas
temos a mania de só falar se em relação
a algumas circunstâncias a o caso
é um santo mesmo final que não sabia
nada nem sequer se lembrava do nome de
ruth e ia num cacilheiro houve uma onda
muito alta e eu toquei na minha mãe da
morena marina engasgou e aí só não for é
nós temos as esculturas do forno a nossa
cabeça
o baile lingüístico ela calar só precisa
de prática
enfim eu quero dizer que o som mesmo
falam fortal mesmo que não sinta a
ensiná lo talvez não sinto essa cidade e
talvez não tinha qualquer coisa ao nosso
percurso do crescimento nos fez deixar
para trás nesse momento da nossa cultura
mas normalmente a comportamentos
inspirados numa sociedade é nós - por ar
que se falasse normalmente foram os
pratos assim como se espera
por exemplo uma mulher ao ir dar à luz
forte mali
espera se que ela corta mistas da coluna
não espera se que ao ver um certo e
sabido grande gravata preta
a rapariga não foi encontrada virgem mas
ela percebeu a partir da vaca vermelha
então eu tá de parabéns a quadrilha foi
encontrada
espera se que o nosso aluno seja
confeccionado com as folhas de ouro
paula como acontece em quase todo o lado
mas tem que obrigatoriamente ser com
perfumado possa me por pimenta e olhando
os clientes que não pode faltar e
tecendo o saber consulta paga essa
coisas que se espera a aaa publicamente
grade
nós somos educados desde a mais tenra
idade na sociedade
eu não sei da família para presente se
nós deixarmos cair ou for é porque se
calhar
é eu não empurrar pra nós mas sim por cá
foi o veículo da nossa cultura da nossa
identidade diz que sons aquela gente que
diz assim o lixo se calhar sou eu tapei
para escalar isso ocorre na sua relação
com o mundo com a natureza funciona a
corda com diversa porto por isso essa
for uma deixa perder dinheiro por lixo
me perdeu estudos para se ver onde é que
vem tudo isso então eu acho que seria
lindo todo é útil para nós aprendermos
mais quem somos e como somos se nós nos
estágios mais atenção aos inspirações na
partida de todo o manancial continuar
nossa em trator ao tradicional e ainda
por cima através dos velhos nichos os
mesmos é muito econômico não precisarão
estar a falar uma série de coisas
uma funcionária situação por exemplo se
uma mulher se uma pessoa quer fazer algo
pra nós a brincar nos o caso da iata e
protegida quer dizer poesia lusófona vai
fazer k1 tá longe da linha como é que eu
quero usar crianças etapa ganha mostra
como é vovó a imensa situação já existem
e que mexam falhas já estão padronizados
é só usar e com essa essa passagem
destes desde já com essa aprendizagem é
é aprendemos também os nossos valores
eu acho que nós vemos todos falavam de
falar cor e também outros criou os
porque eu sou eu não sou pronuncie
cidade
eu acho que é por nós temos força
angulares da cps caminhar é que nós
somos uma sociedade rica cada uma com
sua língua com os seus valores e isso
faz a nossa diversidade cultural ea
nossa riqueza cultural que eu acho que
sim devemos apostar no forno
felizmente hoje
rivas temos aqui o nosso bel o 0 em casa
através da turma visão de que a prova do
que os jovens podem sim senhor lá for
menos 13 com o programa do professor
nicolau qual lado acho que já ensina a
língua e nem tá caro no sistema formal
de ficar só quero o sistema não formal
com isso fazer mais coisas para que não
aconteça como os dois meninos que é uma
escola da trindade a coisa que enviá-los
não tinham nada também pois o primeiro
motor que estava mesmo aula e eles
disseram o início é for em um deus que
sami anan pó antônio rogério ribeiro
trocou ame que essa fruta bom é finita
fogo
ae banana paulo bom criada e aqui o dia
também foi ser também o primeiro dia de
aulas para esses dois jogos que eu
achava e cuja cultura desabafo cunha
partilhou comigo a preocupação que ela
não sabia o que queria falar fazer com
gênios
eu passei na minha experiência de 40
anos e ela existe o hábito lula no aula
sobre alimentação pelo renascer têm
quando se tornam bastante mexe rei
a resposta então eu reitero a minha
ideia do que é é apostar no forno e
apostar na nossa identidade nossa
relação com os outros num melhor
conhecimento do ótimo melhor
relacionamento aceitação outra situação
onde essa cultura da paz
e todas essas coisas muito obrigado
[Música]